mais menaçant vladimir poutine met en
garde contre toute intervention
extérieure dans le conflit au lendemain
de la rencontre organisée à ramstein par
les états unis une rencontre entre une
quarantaine d'états alliée aux
américains pour mieux coordonner l'aide
militaire en faveur de l'ukraine remich
si quelqu'un de l'extérieur intervient
dans les événements
créés des menaces stratégiques est
inacceptable pour nous il doit savoir
que notre réponse sera rapide et
foudroyante
stationnées les troupes russes bombarde
déjà les ponts les voies ferrées pour
ralentir les livraisons d'armes
occidentale et ce mercredi moscou a
annoncé avoir détruit un dépôt azapo
ridja contenant des armes et des
munitions livrés par les états unis des
pays européens une information démentie
par les autorités ukrainiennes face aux
menaces de vladimir poutine londres
appelle à redoubler le soutien militaire
aux ukrainiens
certains soutiennent que nous ne
devrions pas fournir d'armes lourdes par
crainte de provoquer quelque chose de
pire et je pense que l'inaction serait
la plus grande des provocations le temps
est au courage à la prudence un
renforcement des livraisons d'armes
lourdes également décidé lors de la
rencontre de rammstein mardi et pour la
première fois depuis le début du conflit
l'allemagne a annoncé livres et des
blindés de type b par un tournant majeur
dans la politique prudente suivie
jusqu'ici par berlin dans son soutien
militaire à l'ukraine